no do not take off that tux Lin what are
you doing we had a deal I said if you
hurt my mother I will cut off your son's
testicles you're right cut him off
damn what okay as much as I would love
to do that I would like my mom to be
happy it's okay you please have a seat
and just explain to me what is going on
I'm worried I'm just rushing into this I
barely know your mom I don't even know
her favorite kind of soup is it tomato
nobody likes soup Lynn your family of
soup haters what have I done
look do you know why my mom loves you
because you take big risks like how you
got her that dog on your second date
that's kind of the thing to blow up in
my face half the time I mean the dog
worked out great but the dog was a
disaster she hates it but she loved that
you took that shot do you know who never
ever rushes into anything cowards
that's exactly right Rosa cowards and
you're a weirdo I'd call you a hobbit a
human pile of mashed potatoes but you
are no coward Lynn Boyle Lynn linetti
I'm taking your mother's name oh you're
making this hard my mom loves you you
love her now follow your big weird heart
oh you're right it's time for a wedding
dance dad dance wedding with pants yeah
hi guys remember how I told you there
was going to be a surprise later well
the surprise is you're not actually at a
dinner party you're at our wedding
let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
bro
come
when strings are ripe and swelled with
rain ladies and gentlemen we are
gathered here today to marry Andrew
Maxwell Dwyer and April Roberta legend I
guess I kind of hate most things but I
never really seemed to hate you so I
want to spend the rest of my life with
you is that cool yes is it my turn April
you are the most awesome person I have
ever known in my entire life I vow to
protect you from danger I don't care if
I have to fight an Ultimate Fighter or a
bear or him your mom I would take him
down I'm getting mad right now even
thinking about it telling you okay
it feels a little impersonal what did
the officiants say when you got married
not much when gay marriage was legalized
we weren't sure if or when it was gonna
be struck down so speed was of the
essence do you Kevin yes and do you yes
yes we do
we're married I remarked afterwards that
I wished the officiant had been more
efficient it was very funny Kevin still
talks about it huh maybe I should open
with that zinger it is amazingly funny
I'm just not sure this is the right
crowd for no zinger no I cool then I
have nothing
maybe I should wing it love it sustains
you it's like oatmeal okay okay
not bad for winging it I lied to be two
hours the right there we are here today
to celebrate the marriage of Jake
Peralta and Amy Santiago I've known you
both for the last five years
and it has been a true pleasure to watch
your distracting childish rivalry
evolved into a distracting childish
courtship and now into what I'm sure
will be a distracting childish marriage
I'm proud of you and I love you both
permission to say it back permission
granted
Laby captain now I believe you've
prepared your own battles
yes I was going to do an Addams Family
theme drap but my beatboxer isn't here
that's the only reason it's not
happening so Eames today has been a
crazy day but I shouldn't be surprised
because we've had a lot of crazy days
there was our first date our first kiss
the first time you told me you loved me
and the day you told me you would marry
me also yesterday and the day before
that and the day before that because
every single day that I get to be with
someone as amazing as you is crazy to me
I love you and I'm worried about dancing
in front of our friends at the end ok
well I've been planning this wedding for
the last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong I would have had a panic attack
that sent me into the ER but I'm here
and I've never been happier life is
unpredictable not everything's in our
control but as long as you're with the
right people you can handle anything and
you Jake Peralta are the right person
for me
but I do have some bad news there is a
bomb at this wedding as well what your
butt your butt is the bomb there will be
no survivors
wear a tie much
[Music]
[Applause]
you specifically put this one in or do
not play this yes I did
I'm sorry - I think it's your turn wait
what happened yeah okay did you see this
was on YouTube
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
- River
[Music]
[Applause]
bring me
[Music]
[Applause]
I bought those boat tickets the day I
saw that YouTube video I knew we'd need
a back-up plan
the boat was actually planned see the
church was plan B and plan a was
marrying her a long long time ago pretty
much the day I met her
you